ever get that feeling you're stuck
spinning inside your little wheel day in
and day out
only defined
you're right back where you started
and so it goes
day by day
year by year
spinning and spinning
until you're dead
or in my case until you're dead inside
never asking
what am i doing this for
whose dream am i living
[Music]
you are hereby consigned and sentenced
to death by royal order of his majesty
dominus thrax
hero of all
[Music]
get on with it
death by
impalement
how curious
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
back in your place
and
the daring night was slain
or maybe
not
[Music]
[Music]
okay
there
[Music]
the greater
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
what's gotten into you
my world
my rules
[Music]
stop
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
easy
[Music]
oh
[Music]
this is the
intro quest the daviri paradox
so what you're seeing right now is
the onboarding experience
for the quest
where
he gave me no eyes to see him
there i think it's him
sir will the dragon devour us today i
live to serve even as food what
that attack is
didn't you hear it
someone can tell me how our theater
events going
all right
no worries
this is an open world experience but he
does a lot of twists
the world does not look
vibrant it looks rather
colorless
our drifter is living the same day
but something has changed
this place can change
[Music]
let's follow and see where we go
um
[Music]
[Music]
the king
graces us
i
am bombasting
zion
you do remember your courtly playwright
hey hey i am not have you come to join
the performance sire
it would be
my deepest honor to see you command the
stage
yonder you might recover your favorite
mask
my favorite mask
yes manifest as only you are able
with untold power as only you command
you quicksile i can only stall this
awful idiots gallery for a while longer
evidently we have to go find
a match
perhaps we can get some assistance
[Music]
oh
[Music]
how do i know this
[Music]
at least you're not trying to kill me
what
the
hell
back we go
the king
returns
and in such a mood as this he wears
what recitation will you gift us today
i'm not
uh
[ __ ]
line feed of course sire
which
play
now here we find ourselves with a very
important decision as you play through
the open world diviri paradox experience
you're going to be given opportunities
to choose
your attributes your build for that
particular day that play session in this
case players of veteran players of
warframe even new ones will recognize
heat damage as a you know a way to get
your melee built up
in this case we have the option to
instantly summon and mount a loyal cave
which happens to be that skeletal force
i'm riding and then king's rebuke which
is uh a decree that allows you to have a
burst when you um
dodge
i'm gonna go with loyal steed just to
show this off um during tennocon here
today uh this is going to be something
that you'll have so you don't need to
choose from it normally but um we're
just going to use it today for the demo
when i destroyed i bestride him i i soar
i am i i am a hawk he trots the air
cross the air the earth sees the spirit
touches sings when he touches it the
basest horn of his hoof is this
basic torn of his hoof is more musical
the pipe of hers
[Applause]
they
love you
right
duvery is a strange place there's a
place where your choices will allow you
to build
builds for your drifter and what's to
come
and let's take a look at using that uh
decree right now
instant horse
but where to next
so
paradox open world is a strange place
and it seems as though there's another
one of these statues here
let's take a look at that
and light it up
i thought i had lost you for a moment
but you don't get to leave
ah so now i've chosen my respawn point
and i can escape the dragon
[Music]
safety in the caves tenno
[Music]
[Music]
a memory clad in a steel dream
swifter than both shots more loyal than
a steadfast soldier's heart
run through noble cave
whoa now
we are in a very strange place folks
now of course this is a warframe update
but this is also
the introductory quest to the duvery
paradox
so we will see where this goes
[Music]
uh
so
you
finally took the hand
did you
what finally
today's the first
you know how this works
why would today be the first time
your ignorance is second only to your
apathy
what i struggle
to comprehend
is why the other side is even trying to
help you
the other side
who's trying to help
me you are
see
for yourself
you should make a choice here i think
see where it goes
gotta stay true to the poster boy
i
thought so
old dogs and new tricks
go on go wallow in your routine fine i'm
getting out of here on my own
oh
now
that would be a surprise wouldn't it
take my old blades if you want a chance
with that mockery of a dex
we're simply not ready yet
to take on a warframe
i see
until next time
i cannot tell you how long he has
dwelled with us
i only know that something has compelled
him to watch and wait
yes
us
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
got him
[Music]
well looks like i made quick work of
dempas but
[Music]
i'm afraid there's only one way to take
down an airborne beast
i hope i have the
tools to do so
here we go
[Music]
how dare he keep trying to leave
what's out there that's so fascinating
maybe i
should just go there
myself
you